نقف الان في ساحه الرصافي وسط العاصمه
العراقيه بغداد حيث المظاهرات
الشعبيه التي نظمها ناشطون وايضا بعض
الاحزاب السياسيه الناشئه ضد ارتفاع سعر
صرف الدولار مقابل الدينار العراقي هذه
الجماهير تجمهرت هنا في هذه الساحه بالقرب
من مبنى المركزي العراقي
وينمون التحرك في مسيره قصيره ربما وصولا
الى المظاهره امام مبنى البنك المركزي
العراقي الشعارات التي رفعتنا هنا عفوا
تطالب
باعاده سعر صرف همم الدولار مقابل الدينار
العراقي الى السابق عهده والى ايقاف همم
شبهات الفساد والى ايقاف التداول داخل بعض
الشركات المحليه وسط همم بغداد وايضا في
عموم المدن العراقيه
بعض المحتجون قالوا لنا بان اسعار السلع
والبضائع ايضا ازداد ترتفعت في السوق
العراقيه لان السوق العراقيه تعتمد على
البضائع المستورده وبالتالي التاجر يحتاج
الى الدولار همم لشراء هذه البضائع حتى
هذه اللحظه تبدو على المظاهره
مستقره لا توجد نيه للاعتصام هنا حتى هذه
اللحظه بحسب المنظمين سامر يوسف الجزيره
بغداد